hey guys today i have a bit of a
different video for you uh so this may
come as a surprise to many of you but i
do actually have a girlfriend
and even more surprising than that is
that she does not watch any anime
at all so in this video i'll be showing
her a bunch of characters from my
academia who she knows nothing about and
it's her job to guess their quirks and
personality
uh however before we get into it why
don't you uh why don't you just give us
a little brief overview on who you are
and how much you know about my hero
already
hey guys i'm laverne so i'm
mrs turtle quirk i guess um
in terms of my hero damia it's academia
academia
i don't know academia academia um
yeah i don't know much we went
to the cinema to the movies we went to
the movies to see it
and he fell asleep and i i watched the
first like
15 minutes and then i had a nap and then
i woke
up at the climax of the film
and then i think i snoozed off again and
then we left
so that's pretty much the extent
of well we did we did also watch a
couple we watched like the first three
episodes i reckon
and that was a while ago and then it's
been so long that you didn't even
remember
who the main protagonist was like when
we were watching the movie
yeah i don't remember much uh so this is
gonna be literally just
you getting out of nowhere just based on
what they look like really
yeah you want to get into it yeah let's
go first character
so the first thing i want you to do is
try and just like estimate
what you think her personality is like
from this image
so she looks really cheeky uh she looks
super cheeky
mischievous like you don't unpredictable
you don't know what she's gonna do next
different she's a good guy or a bad guy
good
yeah with a like a cheeky streak okay
okay fair enough man i'm good with the
cheeky streak
and in terms of her quirk like her
superpower
what do you think it might be from this
image
uh so she's got a knife i don't
what's that on there is that like a
syringe
oh oh i don't know if she's good now
good guys can have syringes too you know
doctors or someone
yeah okay well okay i'm gonna stick to
she's good i think her quirk is um
injecting people okay okay and
what happens when she injects them you
um it changes your mood okay that's
actually that's actually pretty good
all right well just before we move on to
the next person uh what do you think her
name is
misty she looks like a misty yeah you
know i agree with that
yeah it's not right but i agree with
that
okay cool the next character this guy
very handsome boy okay
bad guy yeah i'm good yeah you're right
you're right he's a bad guy
super bad super evil
always has a cunning plan got disfigured
somehow
at some point um
and now they're just like super angry
about it all the time like in gi joe
that guy he was like super disfigured
i never saw gi joe oh yeah like it's
usually when they've had
or like darth vader like when they're
all like
they've had like a really bad accident
and then they just turn evil
yeah yeah and obvious obviously you can
see in this picture he's smiling a
little bit
why do you think he's smiling because
his plan came together
but it's usually not him that like does
the doing so he probably has like a team
that go out and do the stuff for him and
he's just the mastermind behind it all
i like it i like it and in terms of his
quirk what do you think that could be
i don't even know if he would have one i
feel like sometimes they're just
really smart and they get the idiots
going and therefore they do the plans
for him so no quirk
awesome and name what do you think his
name is
um hector hector yeah okay
cool i was gonna say it's a bit hard to
tell because he has no facial features
basically
no he looks like an evil hector yeah
let's move on to the next one what do
you think his personality
is like like um angry all the
time a bad guy doesn't take any crap
it's a bad guy thing yeah um
in quirk the only reason i feel like
he's a bad guy because like
whenever there's fire involved they
usually are like quite bad like
x-men this is true the fire guy is like
so mean all the time
very true his quirk is fire shooting
fire at people
and like shooting like flame
flames at people when they annoy him
yeah that's basically right
when they annoy him um yeah that's true
and
okay in terms of his name what do you
think his name might be
um brad brad
i think he's too old to be a brad i feel
like nah
he's too old to be a bride no brad okay
let's move on to the next one so cool in
terms of personality what do you think
about this guy
cool um like
quick like with his responses
like a smart mouth but like like
really cool it kind of looks like a
joker would you
do you think you might be a bad guy no
good guy still
yeah a good guy okay well what about his
quirk i think i'll give you a little
hint his design
slightly refers to what his quirk is
it's alluding to what his quirk is
but it's not outright telling you
it's that's keys in the padlock yeah
yeah yeah so he can
put you in a box let's go with that
he can lock you in a box okay cool yeah
but like he creates the box
and then he locks people in them i like
it man i like it yeah
and his name um
oh this is hard ah come on man we got
five seconds on the clock
trevor that's actually right what now
i'm joking
i thought i smashed it of every name in
the world
yeah trevor trevor good guess a good
guess
so this next character personality what
do you get from this image
evil always sad
never happy always looking for revenge
for being wronged
oh yeah yeah oh kate's a bad guy for
sure
yeah and in terms of his quirk can you
gather anything like maybe from this
image
like wind like because the thing like
this ribbon is flying around him yeah so
like when he gets angry he can create
like
whirlwinds and like blow you away
yeah you know that's a good guess that
is a really good guess
and uh and what do you think about his
eyes like they're pretty strange right
i feel like you keep talking about his
eyes oh you know what maybe
subconsciously i keep
yeah can i shoot lasers or something no
but uh well i'm gonna go with that yeah
yeah
like he can he can win power but he can
shoot laces from the red eyes
okay fair enough fair enough that's
almost like two quirks and uh in terms
of his name
oh just from looking at this image i
feel like he maybe has like a european
like a french name or something like
that yeah
but i'm trolling you though because he
does it antonia
okay cool yeah antonio yeah you know
what i can i can buy that
i can buy that so this guy
oh what do you think his personality is
like
always messing up always like
sorry guys i didn't mean to do that
like because look at his eyes like he's
already like worried he's going to mess
up
for the day he looks stressed doesn't he
i've never left his eyes properly yeah
and like the way his hands are up like
i'm really sorry
you know what that is some good uh body
language reading right yeah yeah so he's
quirk i mean he's basically he's in a
washing machine
yeah what could he possibly be
that he can make things clean again and
clean up
around him um
yeah he makes him clean okay okay mr
clean
and yeah and in terms of his his name
either his real name or his hero name
what because oh did i explain that oh so
in this in this
show basically characters they can have
a you know their real legal name
and then they can have a hero name as
well so for example oh my i mean
i don't know how much you know about all
my is that not his name that's not his
real name no that's his hero name
what's his real name his real name is
toshinori
that's his like legal name but his hero
name is alma so they have their two
names
okay so so you can pick either one what
do you think his hero name is or
his real name for this character um
so i think his real name is bruce like a
bruce like oh bruce
uh hero name is meschino
i love that yeah i love that it makes
him sound like fierce and deadly like
you could but then
yeah and then you meet him and he's not
yeah meschino
that is sick okay next one
ew yeah he's a bit gross isn't he a bit
crusty
um so what do you think his personality
could be like
is that a hand on his face yeah so it's
like part of his costume like just hands
all around his body
it's a costume so you can take it off he
can take the hands off yeah the hands
aren't
literally part of him but he just wears
it to look cool i guess gross
what what's his personality yeah
annoying
like why do you have hands all over your
face for if you can just take it off
true what if he thinks it makes him look
edgy though yeah he's just trying to get
attention
um which is annoying so
he's annoying okay and his quirk
but he can make his hands big
so because he looks quite big in that
picture so i feel like he can
um like mr fantastic like stretch his
body and stretch
his hands and his limbs and make them
bigger or smaller
yeah i mean that is a good guess because
i mean he does have hands all over him
so something to do with his body that
would be a good guess yeah like body
contortion but like
superheroey oh so you think he's a hero
maybe
oh no he's a bad guy are you sure why'd
you think that
because his eyes look evil yeah that's
fair enough
they do and uh his name though his name
um five seconds man we got five seconds
oh i don't know don't count down uh
um oh i don't know i think something
uh tony tony
tony okay or mario mario huh
mario or tony okay okay
and it's just like oh mario's at it
again being annoying
being annoying got all his hands on him
we're just heading out yeah yeah okay
so what do you think of him that's all
my nah that's
actually not all my i know why you might
think that
it's actually not online do they know
each other they've met each other once
oh yeah okay so what do you think his
personality is like
um happy always being like
making light of the like if they're in a
bad situation he's always like
don't worry guys we have this we've got
this
teamwork we can do this together like
he's always the optimistic one
and like he gathers the group
and tries to like build up the morale
i like it so you think he's a hero yeah
come on look at that yeah yeah and he's
basically looks like superman almost
yeah
um what do you think his quirk is there
extra strength because he's so muscly so
like
he's just super strong he can like smash
buildings
can like when there's like an old lady
crossing the road and there's a bus
coming he can just move the bus
just stop the bus with his with his
strength yeah that's a solid guess solid
yes
and what do you think his name might be
i'll give you a hint uh unlike most
characters in this show this guy is
american because most characters is
japanese
okay but this one's actually american
yeah so
his hero name would be like something
like
mr something so the kids would be like
we love
mr i think it'd be something literal
you know but that's that's really good
yes i feel like mr strong like that's
what he called himself because he is
strong so that everyone be like mr
strong mr strong
i love that yeah yeah now that's
actually
really accurate like when i tell you
afterwards that you're that's a really
really good guess yay um what do you
think his normal like legal name is
oh uh just like something quite normal
like really normal like robert yeah
okay we'll go with robert yeah what do
you think
i remember him dude from from the movie
yeah
what do you think his personality is
like no i remember him so
he's the one from the film this is when
i woke up when they touch hands
yeah yeah that that is one of the most
iconic moments in like the history of
this franchise
and you were laughing and woke up just
as it happened yeah so they
they reached and they touched hands and
then there was so much light
um but he so he i remember
so he his personality he pretends he
doesn't care but he's always batting for
the like
good team like he's always like oh you
guys are so annoying or dweebs
you're like goody two shoes you're
trying so hard but secretly like
he's part of that team too like he would
never actually be one of the bad guys
it's like who are you kidding like stop
trying to act like you're so like
hard no you summed it up yeah i remember
him yeah
okay so you got his personality down 100
what do you think his quack might be
oh i don't remember that bit well i mean
let's have a look at his costume there
he's got
is that like grenades around his hand or
something yeah so there's a grenade
around his
arm and uh on the back of his head he's
got like a little um
peacock it's pretty wacky but
it's kind of like subtle hints towards
what his quirk is
explosions oh yeah that's it his quack
is actually just called explosion yeah
oh like you got it you got it ding ding
ding nice
so yeah he can like create explosions
from either of his hands and
they get really powerful if he wants
them okay he wants them to yeah
um and his name
[Music]
um
um
his name what like his hero name go for
both yeah his hearing name normal name
so his hero name would be
thunder i like it
and his uh real name
would be
clarke clark really yeah clark
when i hear a clock i think of someone
who's like really smart and like wears
glasses and all that
right that's cause you're thinking of
clark kent oh my god yeah you're right
yeah you're right
gotta separate true well i have a bit of
trivia about this character actually
so you said his her name was thunder
right yeah so
in that manga we actually don't know
what his hero name is why
because he just like basically there's
this one character he wants to tell it
to before he tells it to anyone else
and that character he hasn't seen him
for a while so none of us know what it
is yet
well you heard it here first yes thunder
so
the next character yes with the bang
yeah
you're very stylish i like that what do
you think his personality is like
i feel like he spends more time on his
looks before he goes out
the way he's got his hand okay wait
sorry i'm jumping ahead
uh his personality is like
flamboyant uh he i feel like he always
makes like snide remarks
um i don't think he's a good guy
and i like that he's taking some time on
his appearance because his hair is
rocking yeah man i mean he's wearing a
pair of jeans up to his nose
is that what they oh yeah yeah i mean
his dedication to
to his style yeah is incredible um
so you think he might be a bad guy yeah
yeah he's a bad guy
and what do you think his quirk might be
persuasion
like the way his finger is pointing out
is like
come here and do this and then you would
be you'd feel enticed to do it even if
it's
against what you want to do no that's
solid that's solid
and his name i know this is already like
a superhero name but like mysterio
i like it yeah i can see it man the
hairstyle he does look quite mysterious
yeah
yeah you can only see one eye yeah and
most of his face is covered so yeah i
can i can buy that
and what about this girl what do you
think our personality is like
timid always crying
always needs consoling
but i feel like her quirk is so powerful
that
it's needed that she's always calm i
think her quirk is related to her mood
so if she like screams and cries like
everyone's like calm down
get her to calm down i feel like her
quirk is like when she screams like
the uh walls like vibrate and everyone's
like
grabbing their ears and she's just
always like in distress so she needs to
stay calm
and her name's esme oh esme yeah
not nice nice nice that she gives me
esme vibes
i like it oh i didn't see the horn on
her head though
yeah that is something that she does
have does that maybe change your opinion
slightly
nah nah i'm going to stay stay the
course
i like those guesses they were actually
not too far off at me that one came so
natural
yeah and like the the the way you
described
uh are quite making everyone like you
know like calm down reminding me of uh
logan do you remember when professor x
was like
his power was going crazy yeah
and that is the end of our little slide
show that we had
um so well done on all your guesses i'd
say many of them were very accurate or
like
just you know getting the general vibe a
bit to be honest um so yeah well done
well done
thanks did you uh are you like more
convinced after seeing all those
characters to maybe
start watching my hero academia perhaps
no
damn it damn it my plan failed okay
we'll get we'll
i'll get you again in the next one yeah
are you down to do another one maybe in
the future
okay yeah that's fine the only thing is
like
i think i need to guess like one other
thing about them maybe oh yeah yeah
yeah maybe maybe well let me know down
in the comments anything else that
lavone should be guessing
for the next video um but until then
peace out guys bye